so he calls a jewish member of  parliament who's just elected that she's  standing with people who carry swastikas  well this guy  we should now  out him for who he stands with would you  like to do that well i hear you have  some tape that you would like us to play  yes play this tape  there's a level of uh  admiration i actually have for china  their  basic dictatorship is allowing them  uh to actually turn their economy around  on a dime  wow okay so there you have the real  justin trudeau who was asked what  country he admires the most in the world  and he said china because it's a  dictatorship which is exactly how he's  trying to run canada and he says because  when you shut everybody down then you  can turn the economy on a dime and then  we can go green and do all that stuff  this guy's a phony parliament doesn't  like him i love that they could boom